[Music]
all right everybody let's finish up with
something fun from social media this is
what I'm
[Applause]
liking so last week marked the end of
Hispanic Heritage Month our new season
hadn't premiered quite yet so let's keep
that celebration going with an
eight-year-old boy recently named the
world's youngest Mariachi singer in the
Guinness Book of Records this is
mato oh he's so cute he's been
performing Mariachi worldwide since he
was four and he's just getting started
everybody we have Matteo watching on W
AI San Antonio what's
up how are you I am so good I love
having a fellow Texan on the show always
Mato so how did you get started in
Mariachi I kept following my sister
because I always went to her like
performances and all her stuff and then
one day I really listened to the music
and I really loved the music when I
listened to it
also this this is a tro it is one of our
most important suits in the Mexican
culture yeah it's iconic yeah so do you
think you want to do this forever is
this like a thing you want to do like
sing for the rest of your life yes I
want to sing for the rest of my life and
I'm really having fun and I also want to
sing all over the world and be the best
miachi ever
yeah oh my God Mato I'm gonna fly you
here myself and we're gonna sing
together you want to do that with me yes
please I will sing in Spanish I will
sing I will sing in Spanish with you
Mato I love you so much I more than like
you I love loving you right now oh my
gosh um that's not all though Mato I
want to tell you our season long partner
pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show want to honor
truly Unstoppable people just like you
sir so they're gonna give you a thousand
dollar how's that sound
Mato so
much oh my gosh I love you so much mat
you made me so happy thank you to all
our guests today Arnold Schwarzenegger
Elmo Oscar the BR lawence baren and hyen
and all our friends at 30 Rock and the
NBC page program and of course the
legendary Paul
schaer
y'all have a great day and if it's not
try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home